you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up playing a 300
game had a couple seeks out one four
five one four three so we have to be
real quick with this or no increment
let's try a slob I like this love with a
six okay no Knight c3 I like this idea
if there is an immediate pressure on
this by the night let's go to Queen b6
and reinforce d5
let's get night here clean take so I'll
be taking with the pawn can i play
Bishop d6 No c5 hits like it exchange
Queens first let me do this move forward
hmm okay I'm a little bit happy about
that they've weakened their diagonal
their seventh rank I guess they're gonna
go Queen side and then we're gonna see
f4 might be an idea to clamp down on e5
okay pretty much happy with my position
so far I'm playing with a solid
structure versus the bishop pair mm-hm
and g5 will there be e4 Bishop here f4
and then this move you know let's give
that a shot why not
strike it my favorite square there huh
hmm okay mm-hmm to be careful I don't
know if you I have a good pawn break
here what about taking and then d5 here
I'm gonna give that a shot I've given up
my center like it maybe play e5 now that
I have to worry about upon here let's
expand a little bit with my Queen side
it's a little pawn slinky get this guy
going and keep going yeah I think that
that could be pretty cramping let's see
if he goes in the center I'm gonna take
and now play here or maybe not
Bishop here could be a bit annoying
hmm maybe that was an unwise decision
unwise okay hmm
I wanted to do this but I'm fearing now
this bishop move mm-hmm I'm still gonna
do it yeah have Knight up six foot
pressure on this guy you know let's see
he's a bit restricted my bishop I could
also consider castling
and defend this square with my rook
mm-hmm I don't know if castling rook to
f8 it seems a little bit weird bishop
see form surprise this isn't played a
little bit sooner
takes advantage of the weaknesses I
created up high
night here pawn takes Bishop takes
Bishop takes here mm-hmm
it might be all right with dropping a
pond like that if I could saddle if I
could saddle white with these double
isolated pawns you know I could go
mm-hmm was I gonna say assume say I
could go Queen side I'd be dropping this
guy on grabbing takes here hmm okay less
than a minute
gotta go quicker all right we're gonna
go in this direction Bishop takes I'm
going to take here yeah it's clearly
opened up and I think white is the
better side here let's come back I'm
happy that at least it wasn't the rook
that came here I have a strong bishop
maybe that's about it think about maybe
getting to the seventh rank he's got
that covered
Knight jump into here
actually what's wrong with grabbing this
pawn let's get one back it's down to
okay I guess we're gonna have an
exchange here and I think it's important
that I get my Bishop on this nice
central post office of color bishops I'd
be clinging to trying to hold on to a
draw King up maybe rook to e8 they have
an extra pawn but a couple of them are
split King up night here
you know let's move the King up I need
to get my rook active 95 is an idea it
hits with tempo now let's do that
actually line up hit up the pawn on e3
Bishop here oh I just missed that well
that was a lucky one huh ooh yeah I
don't know they could just played Bishop
to c5 let me go back I was clearly the
worst side there being down a couple
pawns let me let me flip the board yeah
I miscalculated I didn't really
correctly weigh the strength of this
Bishop relocating to the c-4 square by
giving up my center like that it's a
pretty pretty committal decision I think
that this is a pretty normal normal
position here certainly not going to
play perfect chess in three oh I've been
that extra two minutes is a big deal
five minute compared to three so g3 yeah
what I was planning is if this push I
was going to play here and try and break
this down if I ever capture I could get
it
h2 and then maybe jump in here but g3
seemed to be pretty good reply love that
g3
I take hmm this is an important moment
and I'll be curious about this position
right here this middlegame position
Sall pretty solid structure okay two
isolated pawns but I do have the files
from my rooks I don't know how I don't
know if I could really make great use of
these files to be honest I think I think
this idea to take actually this position
is one where I'm struggling to find
another candidate move maybe that's
another reason why I went with this see
going like this these guys will be
stripped he's incredibly important
because if he's not on the C file I have
a set of double isolated pawns and
that's that's pretty serious you know
things like takes takes here I'm taking
like this there's not be five and if we
do it where the Knights are exchanged
it's still really bad you know this is a
wonderful square for the bishop so I
can't let that happen so I don't have a
good pawn break in that of e5 until I
kind of give up my Center so it takes
takes recapture b5 must be quite all
right and now maybe here I should
reconsider yeah maybe maybe this idea
was just not good I should maybe have
looked more into maintaining control
over the light colors on the board with
my pawns I kick him away it would be a
different story if I push here and he's
forced in reverse but 94 seems to be
quite all right and then with the bishop
playing here it combines well they
intersect on the f7 square soon the
bishop on c4 the rook on f1 and then
because of that pressure my position
feels some restriction so if I could do
it over I think I would do without b4
and play e5 immediately yeah I think
this the
this is already an improvement and I
feel pretty confident that the computer
will agree with that yeah - to play b5
like I did and then play e5 without b4 I
can't allow this strong position for the
bishop it's too good he's the one Bishop
that I really have to keep good control
over so and from here who if black is
allowing if white is allowing me to take
here just kind of making a dummy move if
we have this exchange then at least I
could rely upon this square for my
pieces my Knights will find a good home
and that's this should be equal you know
I think that's a fair assessment I'd
prefer to play black here because I
would have the d5 square and doing
something other than that maybe black
has to give this up or maybe even
consider pushing instead of King g2
maybe this is an idea mmm good see it
and pretty sharp now with maybe b5 hmm
I'm not sure you know this might be a
good replying to the to this e5 advance
hmm taking like this I don't I don't
think I have any issue with that now now
if I'm kicking the knight later in this
Knight e4 move happens this is a
different story
double isolated pawns just like I was
referencing earlier about if I don't
have my C pon these two double isolated
pawns are a glaring weakness well
similarly if white does not have their
deep on and then goes in for this double
isolated pawns it's a that's rough
that's that's a big weakness compare
that with what happened in the game this
was a group of three white is still
having their deep on they have control
over the eat the important a five square
so yeah this will be a very critical
moment
here 'if i've d5 I'm not quite sure how
to assess this on b4 white has the in
between move capturing I take if I take
here they take here with check and only
then recapture so I'm not sure on v4
takes here night-night here maybe takes
takes in the night here this is maybe an
improved version you know II for well
maybe maybe even something other than
that how about night here there might be
something buying up the d3 square maybe
he jumps into a four you know this is
this is pretty active okay yeah this is
the big point because I'm worse at this
stage Bishop c4 I'm on my heels the
bishop pair is simply thriving I'm down
a couple pawns one two three three yeah
two pawns should probably just protect
that huh if I could do one better like
something like Bishop to c3 you know
what maybe maybe there's simply no rush
either on the white end doing something
like this and playing b3 it's a little
bit slow
instead of Bishop c3 which is giving up
the bishop pair maybe a little bit too
easy and allowing the damage of the
structure you know in the end they
dropped a piece I'm worse though in this
position I I did not accurately assess
that middle game position is they so
this is where they blundered they push
the pawn but something like this the a5
pawn secures the bishop I don't have b6
and okay maybe I could actually get this
pawn but there's no way I'm better here
hmm
no there's there's moves like this and
then after the knight moves the bishop
could play here with check this a 1
square is covered by the bishop so the
row can't come over to defend but
after a kick of my night let's say here
there's this Bishop check and I'd
actually be getting mated with Rick to
d8 next yeah I guess they just missed
missed this backward move Knight takes
bishop but yeah let's uh review with
stockfish seven and we'll see where we
could make an improvement I'm just
especially interested in that one key
middlegame position so let's give me a
minute and I'll bring it up okay I'm
kind of going to fast forward to this
key point in the middle game I'm pretty
sure it's even ish throughout up until
that point mmm hang on this night a ah4
move I have queen takes and then Bishop
here this is something that I have
missed playing on the white end uh-huh
so I could play with still the bishop
pair well it's suggesting this in order
to maintain that pawn but hey this
Knight looks a little bit weird huh if
he's not going to hunt down my
LightSquared Bishop and I have good
harmony between my conch structure and
my remaining bishop okay yeah okay so
that's something to be on the lookout
for this a very natural hunting down of
the LightSquared Bishop could be met
with takes takes and then here looking
to track down that b3 pawn yeah okay
yeah I've made that mistake before on
the white end and so did my opponent but
I didn't take advantage of it there
didn't see it okay so we went with this
I still have an opportunity for taking
in an Bishop c2 but it wasn't on my
radar
let's take with the night mm-hm
a takes can't be bad shift their g3 and
this is the moment it's the big moment I
just want to give it a little bit of
time too
d take c4 is the move I played and what
it's suggesting and probably b5 there's
nothing wrong with b5 improves some
control of some light squares push it
back and now it does like e5 right away
and I imagine after b4 it's going to
like white this is where there will be a
shift not a big one hmm it's suggesting
night 2 d1 94 hmm doesn't have an issue
with this takes takes it still like C 5
and I'm Bishop c4 does like Knight f6
you know it takes Bishop takes Bishop
takes and you just want me to go grab
that pawn I wasn't able to avoid sit
during the game but the reason why I
didn't do this is because I felt a lot
of pressure
like I can't Castle kingside and I
thought after like this move what am i
doing oh okay it's computer chess
there's this move work to a4 but yeah
this is this is pretty scary it was just
my general feel but of course there's
some concrete solution I guess it is
okay to grab that B to pawn but yeah it
seems super scary during the game to do
this takes what about rook to d1 Bishop
e5 rook here Knight takes e4 as soon as
the rook isn't on the F file mm-hmm so I
guess it's okay but I really have to see
that I could get this pawn right back
mm-hmm let me let me go back a little
bit more doesn't like b4 as the top move
but you know this isn't bad but yeah I'd
like to play this
shrim where i do maintain control over
c-4 I don't want to give this square up
so easily I still think it's the right
idea to keep him on b5 e 5 was pointed
out just a moment ago but I guess
another ideas Knight to b6 e 5 mm-hmm
wants to go with a 4 okay you know I
mean I'm threatening what I already
pointed out to take and then jump into
the d5 square saddle white with this
isolated pawn if it takes I imagine it's
the knight who improves his position by
two ranks and yeah pretty pretty even as
it's saying slight advantage for black
but you know pretty much equal position
on a4 b4 Knight a to Bishop c5 huh yeah
it's pretty pretty sharp position I
don't yet have a reliable home for my
Knights and that concerns me you know no
no you know he could be kicked away this
see Paulo could get rolling maybe even
establish himself on e5 so it's still a
little bit of an uneasy position for
black mm-hmm okay
yeah the one other thing I want to look
at is after this move e5 if white is
doing it passing move like that is this
the right idea to take and then play
into b6 and then focus on this square
yeah black from here has good control
yeah could rely upon that square here d5
and this was one other variation I
wanted to look at after e5 supposed this
move this is the one that I was
considering v4d takes
v takes and not night here because the
double isolated pawns
I'd have six nights e5 mm-hm
Knight f6
he has shielding this rook from seeing
f7 directly yeah it's still still tough
position but uh yeah if white did go
with this I guess is this is the idea to
give that night a kick okay I'm not sure
what more to really talk about in this
one it was really the middlegame
position that one quick point with
Knight h4 you could exchange Cui's
Queens and play Bishop to c2
I have to really remember that one and
when there is that tension between the
Queens and that knight move comes in
could exchange Queens and then
immediately strike at the b3 pawn from
here as it played out I didn't take on
b2 and I'm just worse pawn plus hmm
Knight takes yeah it doesn't like that
rook to h6 I'd rather resign then play
rook to h6 man yeah this isn't something
you want to do haha devoting your rook
to just babysit that pawn so and humans
going to look for something much more
active than these strictly defensive
moves grabbed upon and just came back
another one
mm-hmm okay I guess this final position
isn't so clear huh and now I'm down upon
I have good pieces good minor pieces the
bishop at night I feel like King c7
likes Knight d5 and this is where they
blundered so I guess in this final
position preference for white but I
guess I not so much I pointed out Bishop
here rook to e8 he for uh-huh you don't
have to react you could take here and
beyond the bishop fair
direct stuff yeah if the knight moves
it's a matin - yeah
rook to DA okay yeah on quick end
they're after nine to d5 thought yeah
what caught my attention the most was
that middle gain position and seeing how
well aside from the Queen exchange at
this moment here followed by Bishop c2
aside from missing that idea
keeping that be pawns put keep him right
here go with e5 but still maintain
control over these light squares he's
that x-factor bishop
I have pawns around to watch over those
light so okay well sudden end to this
one but yeah as usual I hope you were
able to still take something away from
this video and I'll catch you the next
one that's all for now
take care bye
you